i did a story yesterday where i talked
about the differences between
republicans and democrats especially
related to holding our own
accountable
and in that video uh i discussed andrew
cuomo
and that there was an unavoidable march
toward impeachment that wasn't uh going
to be able to be
uh
avoided
unavoidable he couldn't avoid it
that's how it works that's how language
works
dumb guy so uh this morning
press conference was held just about 9
30 my time here in southern california
and
andrew cuomo i almost called him chris
again dumb guy
andrew cuomo resigned or he gave his two
weeks notice
and there are a few moments in his press
conference in his announcement video
his live stream that i want to address
because
yes he's doing the right thing he's
leaving he's doing it to save himself
the shame of being the only governor of
the state of new york to ever be
impeached and removed from
office
but he is doing it in a very
recalcitrant way
it's aggressive
it is
trying to give deference to the 11 women
who have accused him of misconduct while
also saying
i didn't know i the rules have changed
i'm an affectionate guy
and i don't believe that is acceptable
it's certainly in a post-metoo era
but it's not acceptable for a leader
for a politician
for someone who is in in charge of
policy decisions especially related to
sexual assault and sexual misconduct and
he is a man who should be intelligent
enough to understand consent
you don't get to just kiss people
without them saying it's okay to touch
me
it's okay to put your body on mine
let's cut to this first clip where he's
talking about this thing that he just
didn't know
i take
full responsibility for my actions
i have been
too familiar with people
my sense of humor can be insensitive and
off-putting
i do hug and kiss people casually
women and men
i have done it all my life
it's who i've been
since i can remember
in my mind
i've never crossed the line with anyone
but
i didn't realize the extent to which the
line has been redrawn
there are generational and cultural
shifts
that i just didn't fully appreciate so
andrew cuomo would take on the old
grandpa approach to his defense here i'm
an old man and i didn't know that the
rules have changed
calling ladies honey and sweetie
kissing him on the cheeks
this doesn't pass the smell test for me
anyway
i think in many ways andrew cuomo has
been um a standout governor
i think he got a little too much praise
for his coveted response especially in
the wake of scandal where they
lied about nursing home deaths
as a as a mechanism to stave off an
investigation that's the that's the
excuse they gave that's not what i'm
saying they said that
but this is not an acceptable excuse
that i kiss a lot of people i hug a lot
of people that's just me
listen i'm an affectionate guy i'm a
hugger
i'm a toucher
but it is common sense that you don't
impose yourself upon someone else
before
getting consent
being told it's okay
it just
that's the way it is
and especially
if you're the governor of the state of
new york
knowing the immense power and and
influence and authority that you have in
that position you have to walk a little
bit more carefully
because of that power the aura of
authority around you
you're not
joe who works down at the jiffy lube
who gets a little fresh with the client
and doesn't know it because he's joe who
works down at the jiffy lube you're the
governor of the state of new york
next up
is again while he apologizes
and says oh i just didn't know he's he's
couching he's hedging his his apology
and and and his uh admitting to what he
did with this is a political witch hunt
it all smacks very much to me
like a trump excuse
now
you know me
i'm a new yorker born and bred
i am a fighter and my instinct is to
fight through this controversy
because i truly believe it is
politically motivated
i believe it is unfair and it is
untruthful and i believe it it demonizes
behavior that is unsustainable for
society
if i could communicate the facts through
the frenzy
new yorkers would understand i believe
that
but when i took my oath as governor
then
it changed
i became a fighter but i became a
fighter for you
and it is your best interest
that i must serve
those are all words that have crossed
the lips of donald trump many times how
unfair it is
that it's politically motivated
which is just another way to say it's a
witch hunt
that uh
that it's untruthful these are lies
if they are lies governor cuomo then why
indeed sir are you resigning
if this is baseless
why
are you resigning
you can't have it both ways that it's a
political witch hunt but then also admit
that a lot of women were offended
that they were uncomfortable they were
made uncomfortable by you and your
advances
not to mention the fact that some of
these accusations rise to the level of
criminal prosecution
reaching under women's blouses and
touching their breasts
running your finger along the belly
button
over to the side of the hip where the
weapon is carried on your female
protective duty state trooper
this isn't just
i didn't know i'm a huggy guy
no
and then finally
the moment where he says he's going to
resign and i think that given the
circumstances
the best way i can help now
is if i step aside and let government
get back to governing
and therefore that's what i'll do
because i work
for you
and doing the right thing
is doing the right thing
for
you because as we say it's not about me
it's about we and in the wake of this
the female lieutenant governor of the
state of new york will be sworn in in
about two weeks or so to be the first
female governor of the state of new york
i i i find myself saying this a lot but
it's
2021. we are on the heels of 2022 and
this is the first female governor in the
history of the state of new york
we can do better than that we can
absolutely do better than that and
listen i know i ruffle a lot of feathers
over on my own channel
when i when i wield criticisms of
democrats when i have things to say that
are critical of joe biden or nancy
pelosi or in this case andrew cuomo
reasonable reasonable people can
disagree
agreeably and reasonably and this might
be one of those cases